sink into the floor wait wait wait wait
wait
wait
wait
[Music]
now you're in the sunken place
let's start watching cable I've been
watching I was watching Poltergeist last
month
I got a question
why don't white people just leave a
house when there's a ghost in the house
it's like an Eddie Murphy bit this idea
of like if if black people were in you
know the leads of a horror movie it
would go very differently oh baby this
is beautiful we got a chandelier hanging
up here kids outside playing it's a
beautiful neighborhood we ain't got
nothing to worry I really love them this
is really nice he hears cat out too bad
we can't stay baby
it turns out everybody whatever race you
are everybody wants the main character
to do the smart thing I felt this
feeling that everyone in the theater was
Chris
everyone is looking through the same set
of eyes
[Music]
get out Stars Chris a black photographer
from Brooklyn who visits his girlfriend
Rose's Family in Upstate New York his
first night there Rose's mom Missy
Armitage pressures Chris into a
hypnotherapy session seemingly to cure
his smoking addiction during the
hypnosis Chris reveals that as a child
his mom died in a hit and run accident
and he feels responsible for her death
because he didn't call for help instead
for reasons he doesn't understand he
watched TV and did nothing and he feels
that same motionlessness during the
session with Missy you can't
why can't I move
you're paralyzed just like I did when
you did nothing now Frozen Missy tells
him to sink into the floor revealing one
of the most iconic movie moments of all
time the sunken place
writer director Jordan peel originally
came up with the sunken place when he
thought about the phenomenon when you're
about to go to sleep but then you feel
like you're falling and catch yourself I
always thought to myself what if you
didn't catch yourself what if you didn't
wake up where would you fall to but
after he wrote the scene he realized
that clearly wasn't the whole story I
really started noticing the parallels to
the prison industrial complex black men
are essentially abducted at a completely
disproportional rate Chris is part of a
system his father was never really
around fathers not being around is an
epidemic in the black community my
father wasn't around tossing black men
to the back of their minds literally and
figuratively the sunken place is a
metaphor for that the sunken Place
itself perfectly captures the feeling of
helplessness that peel was going for
Chris completely loses his agency he can
still perceive reality but that reality
is physically removed from him and his
screams cannot be heard this metaphor
for the loss of agency proved so
powerful that after the release of get
out it entered common lexicon someone in
the sunken place now describes any
disadvantaged person unwilling or unable
to acknowledge the systemic issues
affecting them you know I originally
felt like it was black people but I've
had many people women many people of all
different races tell me they've felt
that a feeling of the voiceless I think
the sunken place has remained so iconic
because it captures a distinct feeling
from deep within our Collective psyche
something you've definitely felt but
have maybe never put into words a
psychological phenomenon felt by black
men and women by those without a voice
and by you watching this video you'll
live in a circum place
in his iconic book beyond the Pleasure
Principle Sigmund Freud identifies one
of the core symptoms of trauma the need
to quote repeat as a current experience
what is repressed instead of as the
physician would prefer to see them do
recollecting it as a fragment of the
past in movies we see this phenomenon
most clearly in the traumatic flashback
where a film cuts from the present day
to a character's past traumatic
experience which we then relive
alongside them throughout Sergio Leone's
famous 1968 Western Once Upon a Time in
the West the main protagonist plays a
harmonica but it's not until the final
showdown that we realize why as he faces
his Nemesis Frank we cut to the main
character as a child and we realize that
Frank forced him to kill his older
brother and then Frank gave him that
harmonica through a cut to the past we
understand the emotional turmoil the
character constantly goes through in the
present when he uses the harmonica this
kind of cut gives a past event the
visceral feeling of a current experience
through editing we eliminate the
distinction between past and present we
can feel the the urgency of this kind of
cut when we compare it to a fade-in
which does make the memory feel distant
because movies are an audio visual
medium they feel uniquely suited to
portray when an actual flashback feels
like showing the past and present side
by side mimics the way we all feel
intrusive thoughts which hijack the
senses and in the most extreme cases
Force the victim to relive the past and
get out uses this exact technique when
Chris has the opportunity to save
Georgina in a way he couldn't with his
mother show him as a kid and show
Georgina one last time to sort of
signify this connection of like if he
doesn't get her now he's never going to
beat his demon and the sunken place
takes this idea of reliving the past one
step further instead of a montage of
shots that still moves the viewer
forward in time the sunken Place removes
the viewer from time altogether if we
consider the sunken Place through
Freud's description of trauma the place
becomes an extreme version of that
repetition of the past Jordan peel has
said that everyone sunk in place would
look different depending on their past
traumatic experience in Chris's sunken
place we see the world only through a
small rectang angle just like the TV he
watched when he was Frozen as a kid and
he does the exact same scratching with
his hands so the terror of the sunken
place is that it's not just a flashback
that comes and goes it is the
never-ending feeling of being literally
trapped in a past event the actual
hijacking of your present this metaphor
feels so much closer to what reliving a
past event feels like than a simple cut
like Freud Jordan peel is clearly onto
something yet the Resonance of the
sunken Place goes beyond Freud's idea of
trauma as a repetition of the past the
sunken place also shows us what can make
a past event so difficult to come to
terms with
open your eyes
since Freud published his original
theories on trauma Scholars have
expanded further on what makes a past
event like Chris's in get out so
difficult to resolve in her book
unclaimed experience Professor Kathy
Carruth points out that it's not just
that the event was intense or disturbing
it also has to be something that quote
is experienced too soon too unexpectedly
to be fully known consider how the movie
in Kanto portrays the exact same event
both with and without trauma the opening
of the movie gives the classic
Exposition we've seen in countless
Disney movies abuela tells the story of
her husband dying and the family gaining
the miracle of the candle which gives
them their Magical Home the story
focuses on Magic and spectacle and uses
soothing music in gradual Fades to make
the event feel like a well-understood
distant memory we hardly see anything
disturbing the destruction of their
former home is only hinted at off-screen
and when her husband dies he simply
Fades away and we're reminded that
through this tragedy the family received
something great contrast this telling
with the exact same event shown later in
the movie after we learned that abuela
has in fact to not yet come to terms
with what happened have never been able
come back here in this flashback we get
to see the cinematic techniques that
make an event feel traumatic something
experienced too unexpectedly to be fully
known instead of gradual fade-ins we get
harsh cuts a shaky camera and tilted
angles we see the violence firsthand
instead of just hints of it and the
story lingers on the suffering
positioning the soldiers at a high angle
with abuela looking powerless and
crucially Mirabelle exists inside of the
memory itself both she and the viewer
have been hijacked from the present and
forced to relive the past through
abuela's eyes and it feels the same as
if it were a current experience
happening right now right in front of us
in that original telling we get a simple
story that makes sense it neatly
explains the current magical situation
of La Familia Madrigal but in this
second telling we feel the uncertainty
of the event that maybe the miracle
doesn't fully protect Abuelo from the
pain and suffering she went through and
that past pain hasn't been fully
addressed or acknowledged through this
retelling Encanto challenges The
Familiar Disney construct that the past
simply becomes myth and instead shows
how mythmaking can actually prevent
generational Trauma from being addressed
sometimes a story is too simple and too
familiar which in the case of Encanto
literally hides the cracks within the
foundation Carruth points out why Freud
turns to literature to explain trauma
because quote like psychoanalysis
literature is interested in the complex
relationship between knowing and not
knowing in other words literature and
storytelling more broadly doesn't always
give simple answers to the central
conflict and in doing so storytelling
provides the same profound ambiguity
that makes traumatic events seemingly
impossible to make sense of and movies
like all art provide that same Insight I
can't tell you oh
because I don't know
in Encanto abuela latches onto the
miracle to safeguard her from her pain
but when unknowns appear like Bruno's
vision and mirabelle's lack of the gift
they expose the uncertainty beneath the
flimsy narrative we saw in the beginning
of the movie the conflict in Encanto
provides a perfect example of why Kathy
Carruth calls her book unclaimed
experience because that's what trauma is
a past event that hasn't yet been
incorporated into a reliable narrative
one that hasn't been claimed leaving
behind an event that is not fully
understood and re-enters the past
through uncontrollable flashbacks
unresolved past experiences large and
small feel Bound in this phenomenon of
the unclaimed experience in get out
Chris hasn't gotten over the death of
his mom but the real trauma like all
trauma is not simply in the tragic event
but in his not knowing I just said dude
you didn't call anyone no why not
[Music]
and that's how Missy gets Chris into his
sunken place like with all her victims
she places him into that limbo of
knowing and not knowing knowing
something is wrong yet not knowing why
he did nothing you're paralyzed
so it's no surprise that the sunken
place is designed to make Chris look
powerless not only can he not move while
in the real world but his screams in the
sunken Place cannot be heard we instead
look down on him at an extreme high
angle and like abuela and Encanto he
tries and fails to reach out and stop it
[Music]
I came here to see you
because I know that now you'll tell me
what you're after
one of the biggest appeals of film is
the promise of resolving one's own
trauma in Once Upon a Time in the West
the harmonica symbolizes the
protagonist's inability to move on from
his brother's death but after the final
showdown with Frank he gives the
harmonica back showing he successfully
got his revenge and beat his demons and
in get out Chris gets a similar
opportunity to overcome his trauma when
he has the chance to save Georgina
having a character act on their past
traumatic memory gives them what
psychologist Pierre Jeanette called the
pleasure of completed action the ACT
allows them to approach and resolve a
traumatic event on their own terms they
can claim the previously unclaimed
experience and apply it to their own
narrative it's a classic element of the
hero's journey so it's no surprise that
this narrative is so popular in
storytelling it creates a strong
narrative Arc and fulfills the fantasy
that one can overcome their demons even
in really intense and gruesome stories a
sense of agency can provide that
narrative fulfillment throughout the
movie Saving Private Ryan we see many
deaths that seem to have been for
nothing like when soldiers drown or when
a soldier gets killed while a medic
tries to save him unlike once Upon a
Time in the West these deaths feel
unjustifiable not only do they happen at
random but they do nothing to help the
war effort or drive the story forward it
makes sense that the movie did trigger
PTSD for combat veterans because it is
full of moments that Freud described as
a quote experience of helplessness these
moments feel like unclaimed experiences
because they don't fit into any
meaningful narrative and it's not just
in the violence that we feel the
meaninglessness of War when the soldiers
begin their mission to find Private Ryan
and bring him home they similarly don't
understand why they're risking their
lives for just one person and throughout
the movie many of their actions do end
up just wasting time and risking lives
even the soldiers personal lives contain
elements of The uncleaned Experience One
textbook traumatic moment comes from the
character Irwin Wayne Who as a kid
pretended to be asleep so his mom
wouldn't talk to him after he shares
that story he says oh I did that exactly
like Kristen get out Irwin doesn't
understand why he remains motionless and
ignored his mom and it's precisely
through Irwin's not knowing through the
constant senseless violence and through
the seemingly mean meaningless mission
to save Ryan that the events of Saving
Private Ryan feel traumatic and
unclaimed and even Ryan himself shown as
an older man at the beginning and end of
the film still looks traumatized from
his past experience but despite all
these traumatic moments the movie tries
to give itself a simple patriotic
narrative
first the movie places the seemingly
pointless violence within a larger
context towards the end of the movie we
get a voiceover of a letter written to
Ryan's mom by a World War II general
which states that the war was a campaign
against tyranny and depression and that
the sacrifices weren't for nothing in
the solemn Pride that must be yours to
have laid so costly a sacrifice
upon the altar of Freedom this poetic
rationale turns unexplainable present
experiences into past justifiable
actions through this speech the film
tells the audience why the violence had
to happen and second the movie gives
Ryan himself the agency to incorporate
his experience into his own narrative
Captain Miller commands Ryan to earn the
sacrifices they all made for him and
when we go back to the present day Ryan
wants to know if his wife thinks he did
exactly that tell me I've led a good
life
she assures him that he did and that
does seem to be the case Ryan has his
conventional white bread family with him
we hear the Patriotic music in the
background and he honors his experience
by saluting Captain Miller's Tombstone
through this ending the movie tells us
that World War II was not an uncleaned
experience because it gave Americans
like Ryan the freedom or the agency to
live a good life a life where traumatic
experiences can actually inspire you
instead of leaving you sunken but war is
rarely that simple what would it look
like if a World War II movie did the
opposite
foreign
the movie Grave of the fireflies is a
Japanese animated movie following the
lives of two siblings sija and satsuko
trying to survive in World War II Japan
like Saving Private Ryan the film begins
and ends with the same scene and the
middle is a flashback of their
experience during World War II but
unlike Saving Private Ryan the opening
scene shows Siege dying all alone
shortly after the war Sita is not
supported or respected like Ryan but
rather called disgusting and disgraceful
his death is one of the many seemingly
meaningless deaths caused by War unlike
Ryan Siege did not earn anything and the
ending scene isn't reality but rather a
dream-like fantasy of a happy reunion
that never occurred in real life so
unlike Saving Private Ryan the war
itself has no meaning to sieja to the
point where he doesn't even know the war
has ended until much later a clear
reminder that even though the war has
actually ended he is still stuck in the
past not knowing what all the violence
was even foreign
foreign the ants provided no relief to
Japanese civilians whose homes and
families are still completely destroyed
whereas Saving Private Ryan reminds us
that some American soldiers like Ryan
got to go back home inspired to live a
good life
[Music]
in the opening scene of grave of the
fireflies a dream like Siege just stands
against a dark background and watches
his real-life equivalent die in a train
station it feels all too familiar to the
sunken place he's not in control of his
story he can only watch himself from a
distance unable to reach out and stop it
periodically on Reddit someone will ask
a question like what is a movie you can
only watch Once what you end up with is
essentially a list of movies where the
central trauma is left unclaimed movies
like Requiem for a Dream Manchester by
the Sea and unsurprisingly Grave of the
fireflies all these movies endings leave
the viewer with the harmonica they leave
the viewer in an unclaimed experience
they cannot escape from they leave them
in the sunken place
and I think a movie like Saving Private
Ryan would get added to this list if
it's beginning and ending changed what
if Ryan was more like Tom in hacksaw
Ridge and like many actual traumatized
veterans visiting his fellow soldiers
tombstones unhappy and Alone movies like
get out and Kanto and Grave of the
fireflies show the impossibility of
turning a traumatic experience into a
neat linear narrative it's sometimes
impossible to reduce a past event
because to do so would erase the
emotional truth of what happened so the
act of trying to turn trauma into a neat
narrative can itself be painful in the
movie Hiroshima monomor a French woman
describes her love affair with a German
soldier during World War II she plans to
a love with him but he died on the same
day France was liberated when her
parents found out about the affair they
locked her in a Cellar where she went
mad once she shares the story with her
Japanese lover in Hiroshima she feels
she has betrayed her own trauma
where were you when she died
I don't want to think about that the
reason you haven't told her this is
because you don't want the woman you
love to know that you are the type of
person who abandons your family in the
hesitancy of these characters to speak
of their past we understand why trauma
is so difficult to put into a story
movies give events a beginning middle
and an end but unclaimed experiences are
experienced not as a story but rather a
Non-Stop disruption that begins out of
nowhere and feels like it'll never end
in other words the French woman's past
feels like the sunken place a place she
and Chris enter without their control
and a place that they cannot Escape
everyone's room and sunken place would
look different
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
I went to this idea of like you know
what's worse than death
and of course this feeling of being
trapped in your own body for
eternity
everyone is looking through the same set
of eyes
[Music]
for dreams
it's a dream
I was in a hole or something
and I couldn't move
how are you
I don't know how are you
in the movie Manchester by the Sea Lee
Chandler mistakenly starts a fire in his
house that kills his three children
later in the movie he has a dream where
he sees his kids and one of them says
this scene directly references a story
told in the seventh chapter of Sigmund
Freud's the interpretation of Dreams
where a father also has a dream where
his son asks him father don't you see
I'm burning the father then awakens to
realize that a candle had fallen on and
burned the body of his dead child who
had recently died of a fever and in
Manchester by the Sea Lee also awakens
to a burning except his burning is the
burning of sauce on the stove Freud told
this story to introduce a question about
dreaming why would the father even stay
asleep and dream of his child instead of
instantly waking up to stop the burning
According to Freud the father wanted a
way to see his child alive which Freud
described as wish fulfillment satisfying
a desire through some involuntary
thought process such as a dream even if
that fulfillment prevents the dreamer
from acting in real life and that's
exactly what happens to Chris when he
stays to watch TV instead of trying to
get help for his mom it's a form of wish
fulfillment
I was watching TV
can I be watching the television and
remember asking myself why I'm not I'm
not doing anything I'm just I'm just
watching the TV I'm TV I'm letting this
contraption sort of offer me a way out
of my responsibilities Chris's denial of
that harsh reality creates a psychosis
that Missy weaponizes into the sunken
place and the sunken Place does feel
very dreamlike especially since peel did
originally associate the sunken place
with the feeling of falling when trying
to sleep so Freud's theory of wish
fulfillment answers Chris's unanswerable
question of why he did nothing to help
his mom the answer is that facing the
possibility of a Dying mom is simply too
much for a child to Bear something too
unexpected what Kathy Caruth calls a
lack of preparedness and the only safe
response is to remain stuck in wish
fulfillment unwilling and unable to face
reality and all these movies contain
elements of wish fulfillment characters
initially deny some part of their
experience such as by Living in a Dream
like Fantasy by overlooking the clear
warning signs or by rejecting reality
entirely
you're not burning so through this lens
the sunken place is a place that
visualizes this Universal feeling of
being stuck the feeling of wanting to
move to make noise to feel grounded but
instead being trapped in a headspace
that keeps you suspended in air in a
nightmare-like state trapped in a
Perpetual state of wish fulfillment
which begs the most important question
of all how do we escape the sunken place
and get out and in the interpretation of
Dreams escaping the sunken place is just
as important as the sunken Place itself
psychologist Jacques Lacon felt that the
idea of waking up plays a huge role in
how we understand trauma where Freud
asked why we dream Lacon asked why do we
awaken when the child asks don't you see
I'm burning Lacon sees the question as a
command for the father to leave the
dream and confront reality in Manchester
by the Sea the obvious reason for Lee to
awaken is to stop the burning on the
stove but the act of Awakening also
affects him in a deeper way it forces
him to confront the reality that his
trauma is not resolved that he has to go
back to Boston because at least there
he's in more control even if it's as
simple as being able to invite his
nephew so you can come visit sometime so
it's no coincidence that Lee makes the
arrangements for his nephew in the scene
immediately after the dream using the
language of chocolate Khan and Sigmund
Freud we can see that the act of
Awakening from Lee's dream is what ended
his state of wish fulfillment allowing
him to accept the unbearability of his
trauma fully aware of the reality of his
situation he can finally admit why he
can't stay in Manchester I can't beat it
so Awakening from the dream becomes the
opposite of wish fulfillment instead of
staying in a state of denial waking up
allows the dreamer to acknowledge the
truth of their trauma two as karuth puts
it bear witness to their trauma in some
way shape or form but getting out of our
sunken places is not always as simple as
Awakening from the dream for Chris and
get out and for all of us it's more
complicated it's weird that that scene I
mean Judith did say unset yo this is
in the annotated screenplay for get out
Jordan peel describes how Chris uses
photography to awaken himself from his
trauma it became this perfect defense
mechanism for Chris specifically in the
party scene he gets uncomfortable and
says I'm gonna take some pictures
his trauma ties into his profession for
somebody who had been through the worst
day of his life when his mom died and
was in the stasis while watching
television it would make sense that he
chose photography he's freezing moments
and collecting them this ability to step
back and investigate through a
telescopic lens from this angle
photography is the antithesis of the
sunken place instead of being forced to
watch the world through a rectangle
Chris controls the rectangle himself he
can move and preserve his memories
instead of being stuck in them when we
first enter Chris's apartment in the
beginning of get out we get a series of
his own photographs one shows a pregnant
black woman and a man walking away from
her the staging in this picture reflects
Chris's own upbringing as a child raised
by a single mother without a father
Chris's father whether he was literally
in in prison or or not there is a
relevance with the idea of The
Disappearance of black men so through
his art Chris literally captured the
trauma of his childhood Chris's
childhood trauma is not fully resolved
yet like Lee in Manchester by the Sea he
does manage to Bear witness to and
Memorial realize his trauma in his case
through photographing the black
experience and this ability to
investigate the world around him
reflects Chris's general perceptiveness
which peel emphasizes with the song in
the background of this scene
[Music]
he's talking about stay woke which I I
needed the whole audience to understand
that the lead character Chris is woke
he's not an idiot he's alert he's going
to be making the right decisions the
phrase stay woke has multiple meanings
in the context of get out the most
obvious reason is what Jordan peel
himself said he wanted to create a
horror movie with a woke black
protagonist someone smarter than the
white people Eddie Murphy described in
horror movies not only does Chris know
when he's in danger but he's also woken
up to Greater systemic issues he
understands the racial undertones
beneath the seemingly innocuous comments
made by the Armitage family and the
guests at the party but in get out
there's another more literal meaning to
staying woke when Chris gets trapped in
the sunken place he's stuck in a dream
like trance so the term also relates to
the sunken Place itself like the phrase
get out stay woke is a command for Chris
to avoid the sunken place and go back to
being that in control Smart protagonist
and Chris isn't the only character to
lose his wokeness both literal and
figurative when he enters the sunken
place in the opening scene Andre
Hayworth starts off savvy and self-aware
like Eddie Murphy understanding his lack
of safety in a white suburb
not today
not me very simple it's a ghost in the
house get the [ __ ] out you know what I
like to do [ __ ] out here man
but once Andre becomes sunken with the
brain of a white man he's no longer
self-aware he's instead trapped in
whatever traumatic dream Missy Armitage
constructed for him living a wish
fulfillments fantasy that he's in no
danger I find that the African-American
experience for me has been
for the most part very good the ghost
told them to get out the house white
people stayed in there now that's a hit
and a half for your ass it is only after
Chris uses his phone to awaken Andre
from the sunken place that Andre utters
the title of the movie the command to
avoid the sunken place the command to
stay woke you know
sorry man
[Music]
according to peel it's no coincidence
that a camera flash is what awakens
Andre and Walter out of their sunken
places as we were making the movie I
realized the implications of camera
phones and how they've become such an
important tool in The Fight Against
Racism it's connected to this idea of
his eyes and point of view as a black
man being his special power he's
equipped to know something [ __ ] up is
going on because he's perceptive his
eyes his art his point of view it's his
weapon in this context to the term
wokeness applies not just to Awakening
from a dream but also to Awakening to
the racism in the world around us and
get out and in unclaimed experience
wokeness is the explicit denial of a
kind of sleep it is the demand to leave
a wish fulfillment dream and wake up to
reality a reality where one confronts
trauma both individual and Collective
Chris uses a camera to awaken people
from their sunken place literally
through a flash camera and
metaphorically by using photography to
acknowledge the systemic issues Chris
faces as a black man and Jordan Peele
does the exact same thing as a filmmaker
through his implementation of the the
sunken place he forces the audience to
Bear witness to the collective trauma
inflicted on black Americans through the
abduction and appropriation of their
bodies so let's go to the sunken Place
uh
not everybody who resonated with get out
is a black person in America and not
everyone who resonated with the sunken
place has experienced the trauma of
feeling responsible for their own
mother's death and yet the sunken place
is a visual representation of something
we have all felt the disruption of our
own narrative the loss of understanding
our entrapment in a past with no escape
and it's a feeling touched on in
countless other works of art the movie
Get Out uses it to comment on black male
enslavement the prison industrial
complex and white people appropriating
black bodies Jordan Peele used in all
two familiar feelings so that when Chris
gets hypnotized everyone is looking
through the same set of eyes the movie
was bringing people together as opposed
to tearing us up further apart that to
me teaches me a ton about the power of
story
trauma is not easily resolved sometimes
it's never fully resolved it's not like
Missy's hypnosis actually cured Chris of
his past and now Chris has to deal with
that new traumatic experience in the
Armitage house another sudden violent
event get out shows us that we can't
always get revenge on the bad guy or
team up to fight some straightforward
cause there's no easy narrative when
trying to address trauma on the
individual or systemic level and that's
what all these movies about trauma
accomplish they show the difficulty and
necessity of acknowledging trauma as it
truly exists and that what matters most
is expressing our issues even if they
can't yet be fully resolved and that's
the beauty of the sunken place it's the
ultimate metaphor for what an unresolved
past event feels like and by seeing that
feeling expressed in a movie get out
wakes us all up it Bridges our own
unclaimed experiences our own feelings
of not knowing with those felt by Chris
there's probably something you're
struggling with and with Sigmund Freud
and Jordan peel and Kathy kruth have
taught me is don't rush into turning
your problem into some neat narrative
simply to acknowledge it to express
what's actually there
sometimes that's brave enough so when I
look at the sunken place I see what
storytelling is capable of and I see a
reminder that you've got to use art to
help Escape your sunken place to get you
out of your motionless wish fulfillment
to use your eyes in this moment so that
now
you see it
foreign
[Music]